malgré cette histoire de chlordécone les
mamans peuvent encore à l'été et ce sera
leur force justement par rapport à la
santé de leur bébé mail vous interroge à
ce sujet pas du tout non aucune
interrogation je préfère encore donné
tout ce qui est plus naturelle au bébé
et puis scientifiquement ça n'a pas été
vraiment démontré qu' il y avait un
passage docteur d'aecon dans le lait
allaiter son bébé un geste protecteur
effectivement mais ça c'était il ya 50
ans dit certains spécialistes
quand les pesticides n'étaient pas
utilisés à outrance dans les cultures de
fruits et légumes
certaines études qui reste encore
discrète montre que le lait maternel
peut être altérée par la présence de
chlordécone
si la maman est contaminé par ce
polluant il y à transmission dans
presque 100 % des cas ont fait par
exemple que le chlordécone à une action
cancérigènes a une action sur le
développement neurologique de l'enfant
et une action métaboliques
c'est à dire qu'il peut entraîner
diabète et obésité et on sait que comme
c'est un perturbateur endocrinien que
c'est comme polluants organiques
persistants
son action est maximale pendant la
grossesse et dans la petite enfance
avant 12 ans donc ça signifie que le
lait maternel quand il a du chlordécone
il est censé en étant donné à un enfant
dans cette tranche d'âge
avant toutes les conséquences que nous
connaissons dans l'étude hibiscus menées
en guadeloupe en 2003 du chlordécone a
été détecté dans 40 % des prélèvements
de lait maternel en 2018 soit quinze ans
plus tard un rapport de l'institut
national de la santé et de la recherche
médicale confirme la dangerosité de ce
polluant
aujourd'hui s'agissant de l'allaitement
aucun protocole légal n'est en place